Let's talk about the System UI
elements of Android Wear.
When we talk about System UI elements,
we talk about cards and
indicators that give the user
the status of the wearable and
show notifications from
services on the user's phone.
Your job as a designer is to keep these
elements from obscuring your design
by placing them carefully.
Cards here are the notification system
that bridges information between
the wearable and a mobile device.
Cards are also how most applications
communicate with users.
The user will be notified on the
wearable about items such as emails and
messages.
We also have this concept of
something called a Peek card.
The Peek card is the top card in
the stream that's partially visible
over the bottom of the watch face.
The API provides the ability to detect
the dimensions of the peek card,
like this red square here.
So that your design can
react to this if necessary.
You have the ability to request that
peek cards by default are hidden, small,
or variable to expand to the contents.
The user also has the ability to force
show or hide a peek card as well.
But you need to design for
all possibilities.
If you have a watch face with
the time shown right at the top,
you can allow a variable peek card
that expands to the full height.
This gives the most notification
information to the user when needed.
If on the otherhand you have the time
at a relatively low position,
you should leave ridge
a small peek card instead.
If you have a round
face with analog hands,
you probably should use
a small peek card as well.
However, the system notifies your
watch face when the bounds of a peek
card change like here.
So that you can rearrange the elements
of your design, if necessary.
Like in this example here where the
clock face has actually resized itself.
Indicators tell the user the status
of the wearable, such as charging,
airplane mode,
connectivity, and so forth.
And the hot word is the phrase,
OK Google, which tells
the user that they can interact with
the watch using voice commands.
When a user activates the wearable, the
hot word can appear on the screen for
a few seconds.
The indicator in the hot word can be
placed in several fixed locations
on the wearable.
If you have a large peek card they
should go at the top of the screen.
When you position these the the bottom,
the system forces a small peek card.
If the edge of the watch face contains
strong visual elements such as ticks or
numbers like this one here.
Then you should place the indicators
at the center of the screen.
Finally, the indicators in hot word are
drawn in the text with no background.
So if you have a watch face with complex
details in the background like text,
you'll need to draw a field background
like these behind the text,
in an appropriate color.